he is one of our favorite guests he is
back at it as a head coach in the
National Football League kind enough to
call us when he did come out of
retirement
he is Bruce Arians how are you coach
great rich how you doing brother I'm
doing great what's it like how's it feel
this is what you wanted yeah it feels
fantastic I actually worked out I was a
little late for you because I was
actually getting worked out what are you
doing what was it what's going on about
a lot of core stuff and getting getting
my from those operations getting a core
back so I get my driver 10 yards further
than this I love it look good that's a
good III do I guess to be a little bit
serious right here I know that when you
came in studio a couple of years ago you
said when you were coaching last time
for the Cardinals that you you sometimes
feared for your life sometimes that you
were getting into it and so it's very
important for you to pay attention to
get in shape I imagine right as well no
doubt it was when I lost 23 pounds of
spring and I could feel the difference
already I'm trying to lose some more
before the first game but they were just
trying to get some strength because it
is a grind and I know what to expect and
I think I've learned what delegate but
I'm not sure I guess as well just you
know being in the heat of the moment or
everything but in terms of again just
getting back into it and whatever you
missed when you're in the CBS booth you
are you are getting that itch scratched
is what you're saying yeah I mean I
wasn't you know there was a couple years
as I hold my gosh we gotta go to camp
I'm not ready then this year I'm going
early no I said what as I'm leaving I'm
leaving Thursday I'm going I'm getting
ready and it was waking up every day
couldn't wait to get here see the guys
and yeah it's been it's been great all
right let's get right into it because
obviously what the Buccaneers when they
drafted Jameis Winston what they were
looking for what they were hoping for
on occasion has been realized but on the
whole has yet to be realized
and everybody in in our business sees
what you've been about and what you've
done with quarterbacks and think you are
the perfect match for him what has your
relationship in with him so far coach
oh it's been fantastic I mean I've known
him he actually came to our football
camp when Jake and I to football
I think it was 12 or 13 and I let him
put on the Superbowl ring and when
you're doing those camps you never know
which guy you're going to touch and it
didn't gave him a dream and we talked
about it all the time it's been a great
relationship you could if anything I'd
ask him quit working so hard
I mean he's his work ethic is ridiculous
and enjoy some time down and but he's
he's everything you could ask for as a
coach as far as a pupil and a
quarterback so what do you think you can
bring out of him well we did put a
better team around him you know we got
to put a running game around him we've
got unbelievable receivers is probably
the best situation I've ever stepped
into receiver wise tight end wise but we
can put a running game around him and a
better defense a better kicking game and
I think those things will help him play
quarterback rather than try to be
Superman and win every game make crazy
throws because he thinks he has to well
what about the off the field stuff about
heads being screwed on right and and the
number of times that he's asked for
second chances and it appears that he
keeps receiving them but Mike I think
them I think one new young guys make
mistakes and he's made his I've been
around a couple of guys that did but
they overcome and they grew up and I
think right now he's in a great place
you got a young child and beautiful
fiancee and I think you said he's in a
great place
Bruce Arians Tampa Bay Bucs head coach
here on the Rich Eisen show your
expectation level for this season would
be what playoffs you know you got to get
in tournament to win the Super Ball and
nothing else will be nothing else would
be acceptable I think if you go into the
season's trying to just get better
that's not me you know we're here to win
and win now so we're a tough division
but you got to get in you got to get
into the playoffs to get to the Super
Bowl and in terms of that running game
you're talking about how is that shaping
up how do you expect to divvy up carries
and and you know got a nice nice battle
Peyton Barbour who I really liked he's
you know he's a he's a downhill thumper
I like that guy and then Ronald Jones
who struggled as a rookie he was
immature
and had a great spring we got andre
ellington healthy from arizona a couple
other guys I think to be good really
good role players so I think we're going
to be fine you've got a good competition
going to right guard and the other four
starters are back so yeah I think that
part of it it's a mindset to you got you
got to run the ball and and be able to
run it when you want to run it so yeah
we've talked a lot about that here and
Todd Bowles being the coordinator of
your defense somebody who you know very
well and and you made sure you got him
there was a lot of conversation as to
whether you were getting him and then
not and then you got him he is your guy
what is he telling you about the
defensive side of the ball what are you
seeing right now we have speed we have a
lot of speed obviously we're gonna miss
jpp for a while but I love the speed we
have on defense especially the kids that
we added in the draft very very much for
a rookie class they've been here for
three days and they retain well from the
spring again a lot of speed and with
Tampa Bay you think of a four-man front
Tampa two defense we're not that so it's
a huge change here
culturally defensively Bruce Arians few
more minutes left with him Buccaneers
head coach on the day the veterans
report here on the Rich Eisen show pass
interference now reviewable you've
you've now been on both sides of it as a
coach and a broadcaster with a truck
that provides coaches with the ability
to review something do you like the idea
were you for it yeah I was I was um you
know I think they're still trying hiring
out that last two minutes everybody's
concerned with the speed of the game but
how about just getting it right you know
I think that's really what we're after
getting it right and you're never gonna
get everybody to agree on what is
passing fair so what is it so let's get
as good as we can
well I mean in terms of that though
coach I mean what about the idea that
you're challenged you throw a flag for
to see if your if your receiver got
interfered with and it comes back well
actually earlier your receiver is the
one who did the interfering now you you
just threw a challenge flag and now you
got a yellow flag on the field for you I
mean yes I did something there I hired a
form
one of the best side judges ever Larry
Rhodes former official and he's not be
in the press box telling me what what is
and what isn't a foul so instead of
teaching a coach I went and got one of
the retired officials who Super Bowls
and that's part of that large coaching
staff that we got no kidding so you're
not the only one coming out of
retirement on this on this okay so how
does that work like it's gonna something
happens and you're gonna wait to hear
him and you're in your in your headset
throw the flag or not is that basically
and you know I have that I have a
reputation of talking to the officials a
lot anyway and so he let me know if I'm
if I'm actually right then I can really
talk loud okay and if I'm wrong I'll
just keep talking no kidding
well I mean so you're just gonna leave
it up to an actual former referee to
make that decision on your part when
it's time to do watched a lot of film
together and he's he's a he's here at
camp with us and teaching our guys the
rules interpretations and that they
change so much I can't keep up with it I
know I know
hey coach I appreciate it you jumping
out of getting ready for the season I'm
thrilled to hear that your earring
you're in good shape and good spirits
and and ready to roll you you know
you're one of the you're one of the best
and you're one of the best at it you're
it's the league's better off for having
you in your position that's for sure I
appreciate that appreciate that brother
that is an absolute fact you take care
let's chat again soon you got it Rick
you go that's Bruce Arians
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app